let's create a blog from scratch with
corno and then publish it out to the web
so inside our studio i'm going to create
a new project new directory
new quartal blog
we'll create that new session let it
switch over to the new environment and
now we're going to test building it
locally cordo has gone ahead and created
a bunch of different files that create
the quarto blog and all the different
kind of hello world examples
we can see those locally just by
checking on the build tab and click
render website and that will build the
blog we can see that we have a
functioning blog post with code as well
as things like an about me page so i
have this locally but i can also say i
want to publish this to the web inside
our studio i can go down to the console
pane
i'm going to click over on the terminal
or the command line interface and do
quarto publish this is going to provide
me with a few options you can publish
the quarto pub which is a free service
that we provide i'm going to do that
because i already have it set up it's
going to ask which account do you want
to use i already have an account on here
but if you don't have an account it'll
ask you to sign up
i'll click enter and it's going to
publish that to quartopub with a
specific name in this case testblog2
i'll click enter and it's going to use
all that information and put it on the
web while it does all this it's going to
build all the web site again all the
blog posts and everything together
re-render all those different components
and then ship it out to the web in the
span of this little speed run we can go
from no blog to new blog to blog on the
internet and go and look at it and now
we have a blog post that we can share
and a blog to share with the world
to learn more about using cordo as a
computational notebook for technical or
scientific communication please check
out the resources at quarto.org thanks